human beings will use anything on hand
to kill
anyone around them
one of the hallmarks of our species is
creativity but that creativity is often
used to destroy it's really amazing all
kinds of sharp
tools from pencils to screwdrivers to
knives to broken glass bottles
then of course you have all your
projectile weapons
and when creativity is combined with
malice the results can be murderous
it's one of the most dangerous things
that you can have in a residence is
antifreeze
that's been used quite a bit to do all
kinds of poisonings the world over you
come across
really
really
odd weapons that people will try to use
murder is almost as old as humanity
itself and as long as crime has been
committed people have been trying to
cover it up
the problem is methods for detecting
foul play have gotten better and better
over time which is why killers today are
so creative
one of the more cunning examples of such
innovation occurred in may 1957 and
yorkshire england
elizabeth barlow was a young mom
living in the uk
and one evening she wasn't feeling well
about eight weeks pregnant uh and she
just couldn't sleep and she just felt
out of sorts
uh and so her husband reports that she
thought she'd take you know a warm bath
like many of us do to kind of maybe do a
reset
a bit better but unfortunately it seems
like she drowned in the bath
it seemed initially as
an unfortunate accident
elizabeth's husband kenneth reports that
she was sweating profusely and vomiting
before her bath
could she have simply passed out and
slipped below the water
i would think that investigators would
look at a scene where someone's drowned
apparently without a struggle and
questioned whether or not they may have
had drugs on board or alcohol or that
maybe they suffered from some kind of
medical issue
initial specimens from elizabeth's body
reveal nothing abnormal inner system
sudden illness seems like a possible
explanation
so gestational diabetes is something
that could absolutely happen to a
pregnant woman with no history of
diabetes you're going to feel fatigue
nausea which some mothers would think
pregnant mothers would think it's just
pregnancy so it's not uncommon that she
would have felt again that fatigue that
run down
that tiredness because sugar is your
fuel and when it's kind of going all
over the place you just don't feel right
the other thing is she was working and
she had other children so there's a lot
going on in this person's life but
kenneth doesn't say that elizabeth has
diabetes or any other medical condition
it isn't until her body is examined
later under different lighting that
another explanation starts to emerge
when they did that in much better
lighting brighter lighting they saw that
there were injection points in her
buttocks
and that did not fit with the story they
were told there was no mention initially
of any kind of injections
so that was a big flag as soon as they
saw those hypodermic needle injection
points
that's when the whole investigation took
a turn
an analysis of elizabeth's tissue
reveals the presence of insulin a
normally occurring substance in the body
that's also used to treat diabetes
insulin is a hormone that's made by the
pancreas
and once in the bloodstream it lowers
the blood sugar levels but not by
destroying the sugar
insulin allows cells to uptake that
sugar move it from the bloodstream into
the cells where it can be used
when insulin is too high it will lower
blood sugar so far beyond normal levels
that the person will begin to experience
symptoms
as their blood sugar drops they may get
dizzy feel faint and could even go into
a seizure or a coma
now just finding insulin is not a big
deal because you should have insulin in
your system we need to be able to
distinguish is this insulin that you
made or is this insulin that has been
injected or you have been exposed to
from an outside source
in elizabeth's case the insulin in her
tissue turned out to be unevenly
distributed indicating that it came from
an outside source but elizabeth isn't a
diabetic so she had no reason to inject
insulin this means that something far
more sinister happened when a woman is
murdered
how often do you find that some sort of
husband boyfriend
or other intimate acquaintance is the
killer
the number varies but overall it's about
50 of the cases
conversely
when a man is killed by wife girlfriend
intimate acquaintance it's more around
three to five percent so there's a
tenfold difference between the two
which is an interesting statistic in
this case it was an intimate
acquaintance her husband kenneth barlow
who was
a nurse
and therefore
quite familiar with insulin and its
effects
and the hypoglycemic convulsions that it
caused
because elizabeth barlow's husband was a
nurse he was a prime suspect he would
definitely not only have access to
insulin but would know that a certain
amount of it would take her life
ultimately kenneth barlow is convicted
of elizabeth's murder and sentenced to
life in prison
barlow was the first documented insulin
murder but not the last
he also isn't the only nurse to use
insulin as a weapon
another thing that comes to mind when we
think about nurses is the angel of death
phenomenon it's well known that there
have been cases in which someone in a
medical setting has taken it upon
themselves to end the life of their
patients and an insulin overdose as
quick acting as well as leaves little
evidence
some of these self-appointed angels may
have deluded themselves into believing
they were doing their patience a favor
but insulin has also undoubtedly been
used to kill for the sake of greed alone
in the 1980s much of the world was
transfixed by the trial of kloss von
below for the attempted murder of his
wife sunny in rhode island
claus von bulow sort of a german
nobleman although that's
debatable socialite a fellow who is most
prominent for being prominent and um
he had married a wealthy woman which
guys like him have this knack of doing
in 1979 she went into a kind of coma
and
her family suspected klaus who i don't
think they liked much anyway considering
him to be a you know fortune hunter they
found in a locked cabinet vial of
insulin and needles
but
the problem was that evidence wasn't
properly found they essentially broke in
so klaus was put on trial uh he was
convicted he appealed and he was
acquitted in his second trial to a large
extent because that initial evidence was
not admissible
there was a time when insulin seemed
like the perfect murder weapon so long
as there was no admissible evidence of
the killer injecting it
today however research makes it easier
to detect
one way we can do this is actually to
look at a ratio between insulin and
c-peptide when you make that
internally when you make insulin you
actually make insulin and c-peptide in a
one-to-one ratio
so
if you have an amount of insulin that's
yours you're going to have a matching
amount of c-peptide
if you have more insulin and your
c-peptide amount does not match that
then that means that you have insulin on
board that's from an outside source
thanks to forensic science insulin is no
longer a murderer's weapon of choice
but there's no shortage of other options
some are even readily available at your
local drugstore
if you've ever used over-the-counter eye
drops you've held a dangerous murder
weapon in your hands the key ingredient
tetrahydrazalene
the first time i ever heard of eye drops
being used for something other than eye
drops
wasn't as a murder weapon
but it was something told to me sort of
half ingest by a woman who worked as a
bartender
she said well you know if people don't
tip or if somebody's a difficult
customer
put some of these drops in their drink
which will you know cause all kinds of
gastrointestinal problems now one theory
about tetrahydrosaline is that it all
comes from
one particular movie
the wedding crashers where somebody has
that very idea let's give someone diary
from hell
the movie the wedding crashers featured
a scene where they
tainted someone's drink with eye drops
and
while there were copycat situations i
don't think people had any clue that it
could be that serious
the myth of tetrahydrosine poisoning
visine that's how most people would
would think of it is that oh one or two
drops three drops or half a bottle
then you will cause someone to have
diarrhea inconvenience an embarrassing
one perhaps
but definitely not anywhere near death
well that's not one of the things it's
going to cause it's not known for that
in any way
in large doses tetrahydrosaline can lead
to
coma seizures difficulty breathing
problems with heart rate and blood
pressure and cause massive reactions
throughout the body
eventually it seems word about the drugs
truly serious effects got around
in october 2018 a woman named jesse
kurzewski calls 9-1-1 to report that a
friend is unconscious in her wisconsin
home
police find the friend who later dies
surrounded by crushed medication in a
scene suggesting she may have overdosed
on purpose
weeks later however lab results show
that the friend died from a fatal dose
of
tetrahydrosaline jessie changes her
story multiple times in her interview
with police at one point admitting she
had given her friend a water bottle
containing six bottles of visine but
only because her friend asked for it
what this compound tends to do is it
actually attacks
or impacts two systems one would be your
circulatory system it kind of can lower
your blood pressure which sounds like oh
good i want low blood pressure you don't
want it to be too blow you know too low
because you need the heart to be pumping
blood to every part of your body so too
low and you're not getting enough oxygen
everywhere and that's not good the other
thing it will impact is your central
nervous system
and if that starts to go offline then
you have an impact of nerves and you're
not able to do all the things that nerve
requires
thinking feeling making command
decisions and then everything will start
to fail after that
the police arrest jessie in july 2019
alleging that she defrauded her friend
of over 290 000 dollars before killing
her and attempting to inherit her estate
yet bottles of eye drops can still be
found in medicine cabinets around the
world
[Music]
i think it's very important that people
keep something like tetrahydrosaline eye
drops out of the hands of little
children because if they get into it
they can have these
catastrophic physical results
fortunately many of the world's most
dangerous substances are off limits to
the general public unfortunately that
doesn't mean the people who have access
to them will use them for good ends
if anyone should have been aware of how
dangerous substances can be misused it
was alexander litvinyenko
alexander levinenko was a
former soviet and russian intelligence
officer i initially had worked for the
kgb and then when the ussr went out of
business in 1991
um much of the kgb's activities was
transferred over to the fsb and
he became close to
one of those people who referred to as
russian oligarchs
boris berazovsky
and
eventually fell a foul of the political
powers especially the growing regime of
vladimir putin
in 1999 lid vinyenko accuses the fsb of
planning to assassinate beravzovsky
concerned for his own safety libenko
flees to london and is granted asylum
there he becomes a journalist a
consultant to british security and an
author of anti-putin books which seems
to have made him some enemies the
litvinenko's main
crime in the eyes of many of his former
associates is that he was an
intelligence officer who went against
his original agency
that is something you do not do
the kgb and successors have a
particularly
bad attitude towards people who betray
the agency and the general rule in that
is that they kill you
on november 1st 2006 liz vignenko meets
two ex-kgb agents andre lugovoy and
dimitri covten for tea at the millennium
hotel in central london he later
develops vomiting and diarrhea and
quickly deteriorates to the point that
he's hospitalized based on his symptoms
he's examined for radiation poisoning
and it's determined that he ingested
polonium-210
not an item on the millennium hotel's
menu but polonium is actually
surprisingly easy to buy
you can go on the internet and find
polonium but it's in such minute
quantities it's not enough to
do harm to someone it's used in certain
manufacturing processes but it's also
used in chemistry labs it's in the
environment around us it's in soil it's
in water sources the problem is when
it's inhaled or ingested
once inhaled or ingested it is 250
billion times
more deadly than cyanide
polonium releases alpha particles and
they travel quickly through tissues
once ingested or inhaled and they mutate
the dna of cells so cells can no longer
function properly
lifenyenko's death takes three weeks and
that is not pleasant
radiation poisoning in some ways
especially in that immediate if it's an
acute poisoning is going to feel like
bad food poisoning
gastrointestinal distress
and and really a pain too in that that
is going to be like oh like double over
you're vomiting diarrhea extreme nausea
but with that and all that dehydration
you're gonna have start having
neurological you know kind of impact and
then of course there are those longer
range terms where it's gonna cause start
causing multiple levels of cell death
and that's when again you'll get a
system-wide failure
radioactive isotopes are incredibly
dangerous poisons and because of that
and there's there's no antidote you can
hope that treatment will mitigate
symptoms and there's pain management
potentially at the end linvanienko's
case becomes an international affair
with investigators scrambling to
determine how polonium got into his
system
there was so much polonium in his
tissues in his body that they knew it
couldn't come from a natural source
the only times they encounter
radioactivity of that magnitude in those
kinds of sources they've clearly been
manufactured
in order to produce the types of
radioisotopes that are used like
polonium-210
it's produced in nuclear reactor
facilities there aren't that many in the
world and even within the ones in the
world
there aren't that many that handle
polonium
and even within polonium there aren't
that many that are enriching
polonium-210
you can get it to the point where you
can narrow it down to it was probably
this lab in this spot as exotic and
deadly as substance as polonium-210 is
as a murder weapon it has a distinctive
radioactive signature so it leaves a
clear trail wherever it moves one thing
that we've been really good at for
at least a hundred years
is using what would now be considered
kind of quite
rudimentary a geiger counter or
radiation counter and that can easily
ping off and say like oh radiation
when investigators examine the scene of
litvinyenko's tea with the xkgb agents
and review the millennium hotel security
camera footage
the details of the case begin to come
into focus
the polonium was in the teapot
and there's no way it got in there all
by itself
and the reason why the the fact it was
so easy to track the polonium that they
were 210 the specific unstable isotope
and track it through is because of that
signature and we have these counters so
not only can you say oh
this is what it happened in the
millennium hotel it was this teapot and
those cups because the counter went off
you can also then track it well who they
the people who were carrying the poison
is you could track it all the way down
to the types of transportation the route
they took whenever they lingered in any
location including in the hotel's own
bathroom down to the stall they used
so everything can be tracked back and
you can map movements and forensically
investigatively that's interesting
because then you can in the modern era
especially in london that time start
pulling all that video footage and
tracking people's movements and matching
it up
with those nuclear traces and you get a
very strong case on who did what when
[Music]
both the british government and the
european court of human rights
find the kremlin responsible for
litvinenko's assassination by radiation
poisoning
the russian official response to this is
that we didn't do it we would have done
it smarter if we had it was the british
who did it because the british have
polonium 210 you know a couple of miles
away in one of their labs and they did
it and blamed it on us and so the blame
game goes back and forth there's a way
that you get rid of people you push them
in front of a train all right you send
assassins to shoot them in the face in
the doorway of their home
they're any number of ways to make
people disappear
but
dosing them with a relatively slow
acting ease i mean this leaves traces
everywhere you go it's radioactive
that strikes me as an extraordinarily
sloppy way to do it
and the kgb as a whole is not noted for
its sloppiness in terms of assassination
they've been doing this for a long time
alexander lit vigneco had no doubt who
his killers were
sorry lip bananko was quite clear
that this had been ordered high up maybe
all the way up to the president's that
is to putin's entourage that he was to
be
eliminated
yeah he had good reason to suppose he he
after all he knew who he had
who was mad at him
uh and that would be the response he
would have that also is one of the
things that's used that if he was
himself
an intelligence operative a
you know kage baynik himself he would
recognize their
handiwork so to speak
the fallout from litvinyanko's murder
didn't go unnoticed by those in the dark
business of carrying out such hits
somewhere the search continues for a way
of killing without a trace